yes sir we can say yes thank you very
much
so uh thank you i'm raghavindran i'm
bioinformatics mentor and research
consultant with find biotech and i will
take you uh i i take this opportunity to
welcome all of you uh for this webinar
on uh
metagenomics analysis and study on
microbiome and also uh for
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so we we understood that metagenomics is
a way to study microorganisms in their
natural environment
dissecting community structures
exploring species richness and
investigating functional roles of these
microbial communities
functional roles that these communities
are different microbial
communities play in many areas related
to human health for
human health and diseases
so in this
program actually i will discuss what you
will learn in the upcoming omics logic
metagenomics program that is going to
start by 23rd of may and this online
program will actually cover
main aspects of meta genomic sequencing
analysis of 16s rrna and other aspects
of
other aspects of metagenomics and
microbiology research using
bioinformatics so at the end of this
program participants will be conducting
independent
or group projects analyzing data mainly
from public domain and to learn
how high impact biomedical publications
are
possible from possible under microbiome
subjects so let's go over the syllabus
in detail to get an overview on the
variety of different bioinformatics
analysis the logic behind the analysis
and different downstream processing
methods you will be
that you will be introduced to in this
specific program
so we start with an introduction to next
generation sequencing for meta genomic
sequencing and this could include whole
genome sequencing and this could also
include a 16s rrna sequencing
and amplicon data types also so we first
start with the overview of tools and
resources that is necessary for this
program like
you will be given an introduction to
various courses projects datasets how to
access uh how to access the associated
resources how to access the tbio info
server platform and how to
get access to different projects and
different
example projects that we are going to
discuss throughout the uh through this
program and then we follow it up with
this
yeah we follow it up with uh
an introduction to
meta-dynamic sequencing and its
application in studying microbial
community in functional bacterial
community analysis so here we are going
to understand about whole metagenome
sequencing and how to understand or how
to identify different um
different phylo genome or follow a phyla
or different
variety of microbial community from the
mapping onto databases like silver and
ncbi etc so we will also deal with
different data formats that is required
for performing such analysis and we will
also
understand the flow general flow of
metagenomics pipeline and we will also
get a practical hands-on on variant
analysis in a few bioinfo server and how
to visualize generally
the mapping and
the mapping of the reads and mapping of
the
of these
leads to the whole genome uh reference
genome
so um
and then we'll uh we will we will go on
to uh visualize uh 16s metagenomics data
so here we are going to
understand the microbial microbiome
variability using
using amplicon sequencing and we are
going to
also
[Music]
use a 16s rrna
sequencing for the identification of
microorganisms to study microbial
community we will also discuss couple of
uh
data from
human gut
project and also data from acne
or how to understand
the data distribution of active data
from ncbi bio project
and
what follows this is an hands-on project
example on human american vet and human
microbiome barrier variability so here
we will demonstrate you uh how to how
the use of
small subunit rna
sequencing is is performed and is used
for identification of microorganisms and
we will also
introduce you to introduce you to the
definition of gut brain access and
microbiome and and its effect on
behavior of the posts and
and
and different analysis downstream
analysis methods that can be performed
after the completion of pipeline uh
with the completion of pipeline analysis
on the 16 sampling on data from tbio
info server and then what follows will
be uh will be a
[Music]
will be a detailed uh
project study an example project study
which i will also demonstrate uh show it
to you in the uh in the in the in the
dynamics logic platform so this is about
metagenomic study on how
how the gut microbiome is affected by a
diet for example a high fat diet and the
normal diet and how this diet has
has an effect and has a has an influence
on
on the behavioral aspects of
a mouse system in this case and you will
also
learn hands-on practice
on performing these downstream analysis
in let's say philosophy uh using pylosic
library in r uh you will also have a
different access to different
visualization uh
different visualization methods that is
used to understand the taxonomic
composition
and you will also given
separate space to learn and practice
pyrolysic analysis code in r
it's excuse me it's not responding for a
moment
yes i got it
and then we will
complete the metagenomics courses by
metagenomic courses by culminating into
giving you information about how to plan
a bioinformatic research project so all
that you have learned so far is going to
come and is going to
end up in
making you develop your own uh project
from publicly available data we will we
will show you or we will guide you how
to explore and how to extract data from
such big data repositories and how to
carefully
design analysis methods that is traded
for your data and then how to perform
this analysis as you have been learning
throughout the program and then how to
get a
get a good biological interpretation and
how to understand the biology and
different phenotypical characteristics
of the sample that you have been using
for the uh for the project and
throughout the um
and through the duration of the program
and for duration of your project uh what
follows after the program you will have
access to mentors for discussion on your
research progress and you will have
access to mentors and different
different people for troubleshooting
your technical support on regular basis
and you'll also get suggestions and
expert feedback on your progress uh
whenever it is required
so let's uh let me help you or let me uh
give you an example by showcasing one of
the project that we recently prepared on
the role of high fat diet on obesity so
before going into uh what are the
different types of analysis possible
using
possible for such a project let's let me
get give you an overview of um what is a
gut microbiome and what follows uh with
the analysis of microbial community
within the gut microbiome so in healthy
adults the gut microbiome exists in a in
a in a state or in a in a mutual
symbiosis state with this host so this
environment of the cut indicates both
the composition and the functional
productivity of the adult gut microbiota
and this gut microbiota may interact
with the host through presentation of
different ligands such as
such as molecular patterns that are
associated with pathogens and the
different metabolites that are produced
and these different molecules are
responsible and these different
molecules will modulate the immune
system or immune homeostasis of the
gastrointestinal tract and
and
as you can see in this comparison the
gut microbiome will have an enormous
impact on the life and also on the uh
status of the stages of the
host
so it it plays a fundamental role in
actually shaping the composition and
and function of the gut and the way the
food is processed and and this becomes
key factor in determining the amount
and the type of material that is
reaching the um reaching the horse's
circulatory system as um
through the growth and production of
microbiota metabolites so in this
perspective we can see that the
[Music]
the relationship between symbiosis and
this meiosis of that microbiome in a
healthy individual and an obese
individual will differ
by their
by their for example difference in the
variability or difference in the
in the different
types of
microbiome that is available or that is
that that one observes the
healthy human gut or uh healthy so to
study this uh in this specific project
what was actually performed is uh a
mouse system or mouse model system was
used to do and it was fed a high fat
diet and a control diet and their
response
to a normal diet and their response to
uh high fat diet is studied and um and
also as some of the microbiome is
actually transferred from the high fat
diet mouse to the normal diet to
understand whether or not this hyper
diet microbiome that is transferred into
a normal microbiome will influence a
behavioral changes to
to generally
to learn about what sort of analysis
that can be performed with this data let
me quickly stop share here and go over
to um
and go over to the learnomix logic
platform
you will find ways to
where i can show you
if i can find this
okay can you see my screen on project 13
yes
yes so after performing background
statistical analysis we can
we can get and listen on how to perform
hands-on
how to set up a pipeline for hands-on
analysis of this extremis amplifon
sequencing data so in this
lesson you will
be guided in a step-by-step process
through how to take the raw data and
then how to perform these analysis
pipeline and how to set up the pipeline
and how to perform the pipeline what are
the different settings that is required
to
get the pipeline running and what are
the different outputs uh output files
that we are going to
that we are going to
consider for downstream analysis and in
the downstream analysis section these
major output files are used to ah
perform downstream analysis using
pylostic and using basic r
tutorial so this
tutorial uh on
how to perform downstream analysis on
this amplicon data
will include
a detail learn the code section where
each and every part of the code has been
explained to you and then
what follows is different data
visualization based on which we can
understand what the data actually tells
so here the data tells the distribution
or proportional abundance of phyla
between the hyper diet and the chow diet
is
different from uh different for the two
different mice so that is what you will
progressively see
when performing this analysis using
that is displayed or that is represented
visualize using different uh
visualization so you also will have
access to uh try
how to try yourself these analysis
methods in a special try it yourself uh
area
let let it load yes where you can learn
from this code and then uh perform these
analysis yourself in the
in the um try it yourself section so
again uh this measure of diversity like
alpha diversity beta diversity which
will also tell you how different these
two mice are uh because of the
difference in their proportional
abundance
of microbiome that characterizes their
that
so
you will get as i mentioned
a detailed explanation of all possible
analysis methods that you can perform
and you'll get a try it up yourself
section where you can
try these analysis methods with the uh
with specific question that is uh
directed to you after learning the
course so with that uh i will actually
pass the stadium to or pass the stage to
earlier